ja aber eine die von ganz weit oben
anfängt und dann einfach runter rutschen
dann zu wem hin zu dir dann auch okay
gut zu wissen
ich sag mal verlorenen bruder werden
code kraft
willkommen in den vier mal bei mir ist
gerade bisschen übersteuerung bisschen
so reingestellt da aber jetzt besser
so also was ich machen wollte war
eigentlich produktiver werden mit den
beiden geht das allerdings nicht so gut
wenn da muss ich erst mal als aufbauen
dass es erst mal kurz ein bisschen
rumlaufen hier was ich eigentlich machen
wollte war mein ingrid bauen lassen das
hätte ich meine scheiß rutsche alter
fertig eingebaut
die schalter aus wer kommt da noch so'n
scheiß doch nur die zusätzlich erstmal
raus und stadt techniker oder hat er
schon immer für technik thomas firma
hatte den geklauten daten geklaut
schaut man bei debitor ein bisschen
spoilern der stelle was ist denn er
läuft es keine ahnung debitor schon 700
folgen voraus aufgenommen alter audio so
sieht das ja auch aus gerade das stimmt
das ist echt rang von oben macht die
suchen ja gar nix er hat ein paar gute
sachen ihres
afag where i live bei dem das ist das
ist heftig okay da möchte ich gar nicht
mehr weiter zu gucken bei solchen leuten
damit ja gar nicht hier
da fühlt man sich richtig schäbigen wohl
doch versöhnlich schlecht aber egal wenn
bei mir wird auch laufen bald ja von der
firma her
ich gebe den film my way
erklär mir mal wie man so eine scheiße
baut ich für eine quelle habe unter
meinem grundstück wie sieht neuer
grundstück eigentlich aus wie ein
bisschen verschönern
ob diese verschiedenheit nennen wir's
verschönert den stürmer her hat gesagt
wir sollen das schöner machen
veronika ein bisschen gemerkt es scheiße
aussieht wir mussten uns dann bis zu
beugen und soweit ich weiß ja immer gute
sachen baut das eure farm steht da der
vorstand am etv dann dachte er die faxen
bei ihm gedacht dann habt ihr den
hingeschrieben und dann hat mein tier
das einen weg genommen
glaub ich schreibe mir noch etwas drauf
konnte ich glaube ich auch ein grund
warum das was ich zur zeit ob das klappt
alles nichts das haus sieht zwar schön
aus aber ich glaube das weiß ich dass
kann und ich mache auch alles
unterirdische auch hier kannst du mir
mal eben kurz erklären was dann
foto weg fließt was ja auch so eine da
passt dann habe ich jetzt hier den mfp
dran alles wunderschön ist ein lv
transformers wie kabel muss sich kräften
die dann aus dem haus heraus kommen muss
kopper cable einfach einfach nur papa
cable das was alle müsste müsste für ihn
okay war das ist ja eh sie denn dann
probiere ich das nochmal aus dieser
müsste dann müsste man noch mega klappt
kann ich da jetzt anschließend zum
beispiel nehmen
nee das ist ja eine ganz andere motto
das ist ja hier das ist ja auch wie
heißt noch mal hier in schwierig wenn in
der alle kraft und das hier ist ja
technik bleibt hier kannst du solche
sachen daran anschließend jetzt ein
kompressor oder und rotary mail twitter
oder eine interaktion fördert sachen das
halt so
die von energie angetrieben werden
welcher wo man induction verdauen und
deutschen börse und das ist so wie ein
ofen nur circa zehn mal so schnell und
arbeitet mit energie und dieser fehler
ist es echt wunderhübsche wär's aber
nicht von uns ich weiß dass von debitor
ich oder ich habe aber leider kein
kompressor steht einfach was ein
perfekter baum auf dieser fakten rutsche
alter ich glaub ich hab die rutsche bei
mir vom grundstück ausgabe die sie recht
bisschen kaka aus wenn die denex gebaut
die sich täglich ja wirklich was wir
wollten nie verbessern wollten wir nicht
nur die riesige karotte machen
ah ja stimmt die karotte
nein wie wenn man ja produktiv sein egal
wenn produkte fahren belohnen wir uns
mit dem bau einer karotte richtig viel
wollen brauchen wir dafür bekommt
ich weiß nicht wie man orangen bekommt
egal es gibt hier überall diese
komischen zeppelin der kraft von den das
stimmt aber wir wollen schon mehr
mehr
nein aber häufig wie jetzt bei den
orangen rote rosen hin geld mit diesen
gelben blümchen schwarz mit kaffee
schwarz war tinten sec brown war produkt
ich kacke
da haben wir das vertrauen kanal mit
wird mit dreck und derek bailey dieser
pläne ist es voll gut geworden hat ja
der ist echt war gut vor allem dass
daraus fließt was suche ich den penis so
genau anders als gedacht
diese sind bei mir im grunde also
leitern dass da so leute irgendwie
einbrechen können oder irgend sowas denn
wir müssen jetzt wie kriegen wir jetzt
mit diese wasserrutsche kaputt und das
wasser davon weg alte 88
ich mache die wasserrutsche mal weg ok
komplett ja aber wirklich wir wollten
eine neue worden er macht eine neue
wasserrutsche ja aber eine die von ganz
weit oben anfängt und dann einfach
runter rutschen dann zu wem hinzu wir
dann auch okay gut zu wissen dass jetzt
alles ab wie kann ich dann ist das
einfach eine luft sprengen kann ich aus
diesem lv trend zwar nur aus einem ding
raus oder welche über geld rot ist sehr
schick als sollten diese komischen
lampen bauen
erstmalig mit tanklager bestimmt ich
weiß es nicht
also fragt mich immer so richtig wollte
ok kann ich an entwarnt messing blog von
dir haben kriege ich eine zwei echten
kompressor dafür hat wahnsinn schien
blog ist schon krass etwas tauschen
hatten pulver aber ich will den ging im
asta ihr könnt ihr mich übrigens an eure
technik daran finden was jeder macht da
wo euer pulver reiser steht und somit
diesen komischen pipes es prinzipiell
einig nicht schwierig deswegen sollte
mit daran für das wär ja ich bin für
dich gerne da wird nicht die man bald
noch in die zauberei glaub ich mache
heute nacht stelle ich mache durch wlan
wieder ein bisschen urlaub
16 tage das bin ich so lange nicht in
den vier mal der der cornea geht einfach
lloret de mar
so kann ich mein letzter stein
bockenheim ich geil ist auch simon
zaccardo ich habe schon gedacht einfach
mal zu klauen kassiert zwar bisschen
gefängnis aber was macht denn dieser bau
der iss sowie eine credit nur viel
besser
echt ja das ist richtig krank das ist
eine curry mit zauberei sein etwa durch
diesen brand packt einfach ein
zauberstab eine spitzhacke rennen das
läuft und er kann nicht kaputt gehen da
braucht keiner haltbarkeit nix
das wollte den verein firma da aber das
muss ich ja mit zauberei und bei der
zauberei füllt mich jetzt immer noch an
deswegen klappt das alles noch nicht so
ganz klar muss arbeitet man ganz kippen
sollte ich glaube ich mache mir das
einfach so ich brauche mein haus echt ab
weil das ist irgendwie das trumpf zwar
schon so ein bisschen sogar den ganzen
anderen aber irgendwie auch nicht
also ich glaube ich mache mir einfach so
eine riesige fläche was mache ich denn
ich will irgendwie kein richtiges haus
ich glaube ich mache einfach so eine
riesige halle
sowieso kein halle
dafür bräuchten besseren bodennähe
verbessere mich so austauschen können so
musste dieser abgewinnen ich komme rein
und dann fangen wir mit dieser art von
scheiße angesteckt so also ich muß
kisten sortieren eigentlich meine der
manager der den d-day sie können ganzen
ärzte rein wie die leute an glücklich
sind dass er für diese wasserrutsche weg
ist freuen sich richtig in mode kommen
aber erfolgen ganz entlein also ich
finde das hier traurig dass ihr euch
aber dafür was dafür kommt dann der
nächste die bessere die mit nicht mit
gewalt sondern mit was anderem wie was
denn die neue wasserrutsche
die wird nämlich krass man muss
aufpassen
hier geht aber zur einrichtung eine
zweite ja ach ja der hat schon gesagt
wer nicht zuhört hat man lange hin und
her kam nach 15 minuten minuten
übrigens kurzen tag machen einmal du
kannst einfach rein cup machen und da
weniger vor weiter auf na ja weil ich
mache ich muss dann ganz gut weg das
gras so deswegen wäre es gut wenn wir
das machen unternehmen
da wäre schon super eagles viel
krimskrams meine ganzen tun drin und ich
habe ich überhaupt kein plan durch das
alles anpacken soll weiß ich versuche
mich war es ein bisschen zu organisieren
klappt aber nicht so geil wie ich das
tun wir lernen wie man die scheiß
richtig kräftig
ich will mit allen kräften oder
definiere scheiße ist braun und kommt
aus dem anus ich will mixed metal ingrid
haben nix mitte links und weise wie das
hinkriege und da steht doch nur shaped
industrial kreft 2 kräftig
könnt ihr mir helfen vielleicht mein
haus ab 200 e in die mit einem leeren
inventar kommt unter axt oder sowas
wann löw mit den behalten nein das
dürfte dann nicht abwarten schenkt euch
dann vielleicht so versuchen so lehre
bei jungen erwachsenen
ich war noch die wasserrutsche fälle ich
wollte jetzt daran gegangen
jaja könnte ich machen ich bau dir aber
bis zu dem stelle ab wird die kaputt ist
und wer es ganz kopten bauen kann ich
kack abbauen
den rest machst du kaputt deshalb baum
ist der beste klassische fälle luft er
wollte nur noch weg sind das können dann
auch gleich kurzen pause machen da nehme
ich dann hathaway dann sieht alles
wieder besser aus freundlich die leute
gucken es uns so gar nicht
weil die hunde so das wäre dann ein
kompletter nicht wenn die gateway
ok was wärst du warst das wird alles
hinweg haben alles darauf du sagt ja ich
weiss nicht eigentlich alles alle
aufgebaut ja ich möchte kompletten
neuanfang diesem projekt bisher mich was
geist geschafft jetzt geht's ab erfolge
ist eigentlich gut genauso geschafft ist
geschafft die wir was die meisten
schafft ja bei denen der macht dann noch
einmal seine late night folgen paar zwei
stunden oder so von daher der den
anwender so viel wenn er in der zeit
wenn er aus 15 minuten würde wie ich
werden dabei 300 oder so was
der wodka alles bei mir abnehmen dass
damit das gibt mir einfach alle sachen
wieder oder ich töte euch danach damit
sicher gehen kann und dann schenke ich
euch was tut mich mal bitte nicht hat
viele ja ok aber schenken gibt mir alle
sachen wieder hey bist dann gebaut von
meinem grundstück ab ich könnte das
gegen euch verwenden so als gefängnis
oder was anderes
wir können reden eigentlich waren wir
besser niemanden
wie diverse leute waren finden diverse
aktionen niemals im gefängnis 40
das nicht so ich hab da sieht man auch
schon mal lief abgebaut
abgepackt blauen abgebaut
und da muss das rotlicht simulator da
kriege ich mit wächter leveln wohl sorgt
der firma her vielleicht mal gut freunde
ich würd sagen wir machen eben ganz kurz
ein café kurz weg und dann komische
wieder in fünf minuten in der zeit könnt
ihr mir schon aus wechselnden okay dann
nach 20 sammeln machen wo jeder seine
aufnahme aufbricht da hatte ich mache
eben ich sag mal eben kurz das ganze
holz noch auf dem boden liegt warte ich
schlief dann trotzdem den server damit
hier keine sich allein dass sie das top
spiel was ich muss man ganz gut sie
gucken ja okay ich liebe liebe auch
ebensee freunde dann sehen wir uns im
nächsten jahr wieder für euch ist es
jetzt wahrscheinlich längere zeit als
bei uns wo uns ein paar minuten bis bald